bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 78 sur TVF en direct jusqu'à
19h en ce 8 avril voici quelques uns des
titres que nous allons développer ce
soir les communes sont réticentes à
modifier les rythmes scolaires avant
2014 et pourtant certaines s'y sont
mises c'est le cas de de trappe nous
verrons quelles évolutions seront
apporté au calendrier scolaire dans un
instant et la réaction également d'une
directrice d'école sur la commune qui
est avec nous sur le plateau un nouveau
centre de psychiatrie infantau juvénil à
morpa le site dépend du centre Charco de
plaisir il accueille des enfants et des
adolescents atteints de troubl Mau en
tennis de table un derby local attendu
au Palais des Sports entre élencour et
voisin le Bretonneux pour le compte du
championnat de France de National 2 le
club de voisins malgré la blessure de sa
joueuse vedette abatue et en cour 10
matchs à 6 et reste toujours en course
pour la montée en Nationale une épuile
l'Entente Athlétique de 50 ans en yeline
multiplie les performances quatre
médailles glanées à l'occasion des
championnats de France Espoir cet hiver
c'est le meilleur club du département il
est aussi classé dans le Top 20 national
le secret de sa réussite tout à l'heure
pour ce point sur le sport nous
retrouverons d'ailleurs Anthony Resche
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir WIF le 78 sport
dans une vingtaine de minutes oui au
menu de ce 78 sport du Rollo Requet les
chocs se préparent à jouer les play-offs
de National 3 leur entraîneur Benjamin
ferrence sera avec nous sur ce plateau
pour expliquer les ambitions du club
avant cette phase finale je recevrai
également Francis ponce l'organisateur
de la 4e édition de la ronde des
butineuses cette course toujours aussi
original qui se déroule ce weekend et
puis comme d'habitude en fin d'émission
tous les résultats du weekend merci
Antony on vous retrouve dans un peu
moins d'une demi-heure donc pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 sport et on va
débuter par cette question d'éducation
nous faisons le point sur la réforme des
rythmes
scolaires l'actualité de ce 8 avril
c'est donc la réforme des rythmes
scolaires demi-journée de cours
supplémentaires réorganisation globale
du programme les communes se sont
prononcé fin mars majoritairement pour
un report en 2014 à l'exception notable
dans les Yvelines de la commune de
poissie et de la commune de trappe dès
le mois de septembre les enseignants les
parents le personnel communal et bien
sûr les enfants vont devoir changer
leurs habitudes je reçois donc Françoise
Delcroix bonsoir vous êtes directrice de
l'école maternelle Anne Franck à trappe
vous n'êtes pas syndiqué je le précise
en tout cas concerné au premier plan par
ce changement radical des rythmes
scolaires pour vous c'est dès 2013 sur
la commune de trappe est-ce que c'est
trop tôt pour nous c'est trop tôt oui
pour moi c'est trop tôt et pour la
majorité de mes collègues c'est trop tôt
presque je dirais à l'unanimité les
écoles s'étaient exprimé dans les mois
qui ont précédé pour demander un report
à 2014 vous aviez demandé effectivement
ce report en 2014 comme beaucoup
d'écoles sur la commune de trappe vous
avez échangé avec les différents
enseignants je crois que c'est
pratiquement l'un imité des écoles de
trappe qui ont fait cette demande de
report à 2014 vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi justement vous préférez que ça
se ce soit mise en place en 2014 plutôt
qu'en 2013 et juste après ce premier
reportage de la rédaction les précisions
sur cette réforme des rythmes scolaires
avec Julie Rocha
Soarez les écoliers de trappe auront
école le mercredi matin dès la rentrée
2013 une décision officielle prise après
un mois de consultation sur les rythmes
de l'enfant pour le contenu de cette
demi-journée supplémentaire rien n'est
encore défini elle pourrait se diviser
en 3IS temps garderie animation et
éducation les autres jours l'accueil se
ferait toujours desès 7h30 pour un début
de l'enseignement à 9h après une pause
de 2h les cours reprendraient de 14h à
16h30 le créneau jusqu'à 18h30 est
réservé pour le moment à la garderie et
l'aide au devoirs des évolutions du
temps périscolaire sont encore à
déterminer nous sommes en train de
préparer avec un rendez-vous avec le
directeur régional du CNFPT de façon à
former nos animateurs au-dessus du du
BAFA de façon à correspondre à des
activités plus culturel et qui assure un
prolongement de ce qui se fait dans le
projet éducatif la commune s'engage à
financer ce projet qui concernera sur le
long terme les élèves de 2 à 18 ans mais
les inquiétudes des parents persistent
sur cette nouvelle semaine de 4 jours et
demi et VO ce qu'ils en ont besoin
comment ça va être
fait je sais pas comment ça va se passer
quel cours ils auront est-ce que ce sera
des cours qui seront lourds comme la
lecture ou les mathématiques ou est-ce
que ça sera des activités enfin ou
peut-être ce sera super ouais peut-être
faut voir des questionnements qui
resteront en suspens en attendant la
réunion publique prévue par la ville
mercredi 10 avril à l'auditorium de
trappe dès
19h30 et cette réunion du 10 avril 19h à
trappe pourrait être agitée on annonce
une mobilisation des enseignants des
parents d'élèves aussi qui s'opposent à
cette date de 2013 vous ferez partie des
des manifestants de ce 10 pr partie en
effet nous sommes nombreux je crois à
vouloir exprimer notre désaccord ou en
tout cas notre inquiétude est-ce qu'il
est possible de faire revenir la
municipalité sur ce choix de 2013 ça
semble compliqué je l'ignore ça semble
compliqué sur le choix de 2013 ça me
paraît difficile maintenant si onexprime
pas les choses on peut pas être entendu
j'en reviens à ce qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure dans ce reportage l'accueil se
ferait dorén avant des 7h30 pour un
début de l'enseignement à 9h après une
pause de 2h les cours reprendrai de 14h
à 16h30 le créneau jusqu'à 18h30 réservé
pour le moment en garderie aide à la
devoir au devoir ce nouveau rythme ne ne
change pas fondamentalement les choses
même pour le rythme de l'enfant décalé
d'une demi-heure le matin ça sert pas à
grand-chose j'ai pas le sentiment que ça
modifie beaucoup le le rythme de
l'enfant parce que soit il arrivera à 9h
moin le qu à l'école il aura en effet
gagner une demi-heure de sommeil soit
étant donné qu'il y a énormément de
parents qui n'ont pas des horaires très
maléables qui ont des employeurs qui les
les attendent ils seront déposés en
garderie le matin très tôt à 7h30 ou 8h
ou plus tard 8h20 puisque c'était
l'heure précédente et il leur journée
sera sera pas ne sera pas
significativement
allégé puisque de toute façon ils
termineront à la même heure à 16h30
enfin c'est le sentiment que nous avons
et vous nous dites les enfants sont plus
réceptifs le matin auss si vous auriez
préféré dans le cadre de cette
réorganisation des horaires peut-être
que la journée se termine plus tôt mais
qu'elle commence toujours la même heure
c'est-à-dire vers 8h30 c'est notre
constat nous à nous enseignants nous
sommes au contact des enfants toute la
journée tous les jours nous constatons
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus disponibles
pour les apprentissages entre 8h30 et 9h
le matin qu'ils ne le sont entre 16h et
16h30 est-ce que vous êtes contre cette
semaine de 5 jours tout simplement du
tout pas du tout nous sommes
majoritairement pour cette semaine de 15
jours de 5 jours nous trouvons en effet
que les enfants depuis le passage à la
semaine de 4 jours avait des journées
trop longues il a fallu concentrer en 4
jours ce qui était avant en 4 jours et
demi d'enseignement ça leur a donné des
journées très chargées donc nous sommes
très pour le passage à la semaine de 5
jours mais plutôt en 2014 avec une
réflexion prolongée et les enseignants
VO ce que nous aus souhaité c'est
d'abord être mieux entendu en tant
qu'enseignant être plus considérés comme
des intervenants des interlocuteurs on a
demandé à être reçu par le maire on n'y
est pas parvenu donc on aurait préféré
être entendu plus longuement et puis
prendre le temps d'une véritable
concertation pour construire un
véritable projet qui soit ambitieux pour
nos expliqué les les motivations de
cette réforme dès 2013 ou pas encore non
pour l'instant nous n'en avons pas de
d'explication nous les attendons demain
mais vous comprenez que ça puisse être
aussi d'ordre budgétaire parce que les
communes qui vont dès 2013 mettre en
place la réforme des aides de l'État ce
qui n'est pas le cas pour les communes
qui attendront 2014 oui nous le savons
parfaitement nous le savons parfaitement
mais pour nous enseignants c'est
difficile de considérer qu'il puisse y
avoir une logique
budgétaire mise en balance par rapport
au bien des élèves justement les parents
qu'en pensent-ils puisque les élèves ce
sont leurs enfants alors les parents de
trappe voici quelques réactions à la
sortie des écoles ce midi j'appréhende
un peu parce que du coup c'est une
organisation à prévoir mes filles par
exemple ont l'habitude en fait d'avoir
des activités le matin le mercredi matin
et donc maintenant à savoir comment ça
va se passer et puis aussi pendant
pendant les horaires à quelle heure
elles vont finir comment on va
s'arranger pour le mode de garde qui va
venir les chercher je sais pas encore
parce que j'attends j'attends la réunion
à la mairie pour savoir exactement ce
qu'on nous propose et puis après on
avisera mais de toute façon je suis pas
je suis pas pour oh le mercredi du
moment qu'il a l'après-midi pour se
reposer ça va on a des enfants en
difficulté au sein de notre famille et
et après ça ça engendre toute une
réorganisation surtout qu'il y a pas mal
de parents isolés et ça ils en parlent
pas du tout donc c'est bien de faire du
forcing mais le souci c'est que il y a
il va y avoir au niveau de pas mal de
familles sur la commune de Trapp pas mal
d'impact pas mal d'impact vous le
ressentez est-ce que les parents vous en
ont parlé aussi déjà alors déjà nous
nous avons les représentants de parents
d'élèves qui non seulement nous en ont
parlé mais au sein des conseil d'école
dans plus maintenant de la moitié je
crois qu'on est à plus d'une vingtaine
d'écoles sur trappe il a été voté
desmtions à l'unanimité par les
enseignants et les représentants de
parents d'élèves pour demander un autre
aménagement des horaires c'est des
divisions du côté des parents d'élèves
hein la FCPE n'est pas unanime sur cette
question 2013-204 la la FCPE n'est en
effet pas unanime nous nous avons quatre
représentants de parents FCPE à l'école
qui sont unanimes pour un report à
2014 je crois que presque toutes les
écoles de trappe avaient voté une motion
au conseil d'école pour le report à 2014
on n est plus là forcément actuellement
mais pour le changement d'horaire nous
sommes aujourd'hui plus d'une vingtaine
d'écoles à avoir demandé envoyé donc à
Monsieur le Maire Monsieur Malandin à
Monsieur Coignard notre directeur
académique et à Madame lafge notre
inspectrice deéducation nationale le
trap nos propositions voilà donc pour
résumer si 2013 devait se faire et ce
qui semble plutôt parti sur la ville de
trappe vous l'accepteriez forcément
puisque vous êtes tout simplement obligé
en tant qu'enseignant mais pour autant
vous souhaiteriez qu'on revoit peut-être
les horaires de toute façon nous sommes
fonctionnaires donc nous nous sommes
nous avons des limites dans ce que qui
passé à 2013 autant vous écouter pour
que les horaires soient peut-être
décalés ça nous paraît extrêmement
important parce que les les deux entre
autres on n a pas parlé mais les 2h
seulement de classe le mercredi matin
nous semble vraim une demi-heure de
décalage chaque matin moins d'heure dans
la journée avec cette demi-heure décalé
le matin et finalement le mercredi les 2
heures pour rattraper voilà c'est ça
seulement une demi-heure de moins le
matin on finit aussi tard le soir pour
les enfants et le mercredi les 2hures
qu'il nous reste à rattraper c'est un
espace très très court pour mettre en
œuvre des activités ça ça nous paraît un
peu difficile merci de ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes directrice de
l'écolan Franck à traap Trapp qui a donc
fait le choix de 2013 pour la mise en
place des nouveaux rythmes il y aura une
présentation auprès des enseignants dès
le mardi mercredi réunion également avec
les parents qui pourront échanger ce
sera à l'auditorium de trappe et une
manifestation il est d'ailleurs prévu
des opposants les discussions qui vont
donc se poursuivre même si la commune a
fait ce choix de 2013 c'est l'une des
rares communes dans les ivelines à avoir
fait ce choix merci à vous dans un
instant nous reviendrons sur le bilan du
site d'action l'ouverture de la semaine
du handicap à en cours également pour
l'instant le point sur le nouveau centre
de psychiatrie Infanto juvénil à morpa
un site qui dépend du centre Charco de
plaisir il accueille des enfants des
adolescents atteint de troubles mentaux
Julie Rochat Suarez pour ce
reportage après celle de rambouiller il
y a un an le centre hospitalier
Jean-Martin Charcot de plaisir a
inauguré une nouvelle structure de
psychiatrie infantau-juvénile en plein
centreville de morpa elle regroupe
l'ancienne structure de morpa plus la
structure de la verrière qui a été
rapatriée ici pour fusionner les équipes
et donner un plus un plateau technique
mieux équipé et plus plus agréable aux
enfants au total 1000 enfants et
adolescents atteints de troubles mentaux
qui sont accueillis quotidiennement pour
des consultations ou des ateliers
thérapeutiques pour prendre en charge
leur pathologie 5 médecins
pédopsychiatres et une trentaine de
personnel médical dont un nouveau
psychologue à mi-temps ces nouveaux
locaux aménagés sur 600 m Carr sont
considérés comme un atout en plus on a
un mobilier qui est adapté donc T est s
roulette on le pousse on peut mettre
dans les couloirs on exploite la sol si
on veut l'atelier lumineux permet aussi
d'utiliser plus de matériel et de
développer des projets avec les
adolescents des projets parfois
étonnants c'est peut-être le seul
endroit ici où ils savent que c'est pour
eux et que ils vont pouvoir amener leur
projet comme ils veulent et que les gens
travaillent voilà avec eux à leur
service on leur fait faire des armes en
carton des cartons de
récupération pour tirer des élastiques
par exemple et leur apprendre ainsi
comme
enfin maîtriser la violence ce pôle de
pédopsychiatrie concerne 90 communes qui
sétendent de 50 ans en iveline jusqu'à
remouiller